vamos a encontrar la suma de menos 15
más menos 46 más menos 29 y vamos a
dibujar gráficamente cada uno de estos
números usando líneas menos 15 va a
verse así estamos dibujando una línea y
si aquí ponemos el 0 menos 15 va a estar
en esta posición así que ya indicamos la
posición de este menos 15 con este color
morado y vamos a dibujar aquí una flecha
del 0 al menos 15 esta flecha es un
vector y me está indicando que la
magnitud de esta de este vector es 15 y
la dirección hacia la izquierda me
indica que es un número negativo ahora
vamos a hacer lo mismo para nuestro
número menos 46 vamos a dibujar nuestra
línea dibujamos nuestra línea numérica
así
y aquí ponemos el 0 y aquí va a estar el
menos 46 y ponemos de nuevo una flecha
ahora de color verde con la magnitud 46
y la dirección hacia la izquierda
indicando que es un número negativo esta
distancia de acá que estoy señalando es
el número 46 y es el valor absoluto lo
que le va a dar el sentido negativo
indicarnos que es un número negativo es
la flecha o para ser más precisos el
sentido de la flecha que estoy dibujando
me indica que es menos 46 en cambio si
el sentido de la flecha fuera hacia la
derecha indicaría un número positivo y
como se pueden imaginar vamos a hacer
exactamente lo mismo para nuestro número
menos 29 así que permítanme dibujar mi
línea de números
dibujamos nuestra recta en amarillo aquí
el 0 y ahora el menos 29 va a estar más
o menos por acá y vamos a dibujar el
valor absoluto con este color naranja
aquí ponemos 29 y la cantidad negativa
va a ser por el sentido de la flecha
hacia la izquierda
si hubiera sido 29 positivo el sentido
de la flecha sería hacia la derecha y
bueno ahora podemos ver todos los
valores y vamos a ver qué pasa cuando
los mamos una manera de hacerlo es sumar
las flechas es decir poner cada flecha
en donde termina una flecha anterior por
ejemplo si tenemos esta de menos 15
donde termina esta flecha vamos a poner
la flecha que corresponde al menos 46 es
más vamos a dibujarlo aquí está nuestra
línea de números con sus flechitas aquí
está el cero aquí dibujo el menos 15
dibujamos 15 espacios en morado aquí
hacia la izquierda
aquí está y ahora donde terminó al menos
15 voy a dibujar el menos 46 así que
aquí voy a ponerlo en color verde
más o menos así en color verde
y es la cantidad del valor absoluto de
46 esta magnitud lo que voy a dibujar
aquí y la flecha el sentido de la flecha
me va a indicar que es un número
negativo así que este menos 46 lo estoy
poniendo justo donde está terminando el
menos 15 aunque todavía no sé
exactamente cuál es la cantidad que va
aquí al menos ya tengo las magnitudes
correspondientes sé que la magnitud de
esta flecha es 46 y que la magnitud de
esta otra es de 15 aquí lo escribimos
con el color que corresponde y ahora
tengo esta flecha naranja que vamos a
hacer lo mismo la vamos a dibujar justo
donde termina la flecha verde entonces
aquí ponemos la magnitud que corresponde
con la flecha hacia la izquierda
indicando número negativo y escribimos
la magnitud 29 ahora la magnitud total
de todo esto va a ser la suma de 15 46
más 29 pero va a estar con sentido hacia
la izquierda es decir va a ser una
cantidad negativa y esto es lo mismo que
decir bueno voy a tomar el valor
absoluto de menos 15 más
el valor absoluto de menos 46 más el
valor absoluto de menos 29 y al final
tomamos el valor negativo de esto así
que vamos a hacerlo vamos a sumar 15 más
46 más 29 más 29 y ahora hacemos la suma
56 11 más 9 20 aquí ponemos el 22 más 13
más 4 son 7 más 2 son nueve escribimos 9
y nos queda 90 entonces la longitud de
todo este segmento va a ser 90 pero con
la dirección hacia la izquierda
indicando que va a ser número negativo
si fuera un 90 positivo el sentido de la
flecha y hacia la derecha pero es un
menos 90 así que va el sentido hacia la
izquierda así que el resultado de
nuestra suma de números negativos va a
ser igual a menos 90 podemos escribir
esto como que es igual a el negativo del
valor absoluto de menos 15
más el valor absoluto de menos 46 más el
valor absoluto de menos 29 y la razón de
escribir esto de esta manera es porque
aunque se ve un poco sofisticado
realmente esta es la parte del -15 es el
valor absoluto de esta flecha el valor
absoluto de menos 46 es en realidad esta
flecha y el valor absoluto de menos 29
es esta flecha que tenemos acá en
naranja así que 15 más 46 más 29 nos da
90 pero es hacia la izquierda por lo que
nos da una cantidad negativa